7 chaque découverte de grottes
préhistoriques risque de détruire les
oeuvres peintes par nos ancêtres
il y à quelques vingt mille quarante
mille ans les oeuvres ne supporte pas la
lumière ni la respiration des visiteurs
quatre grottes viennent d'être fermés en
dordogne
la plus célèbre celle de lascaux est
interdit au public depuis 11 ans déjà
monsieur sarradet comment se fait-il que
vous fermiez les grottes au moment où
les touristes viennent et bien
précisément au bénéfice des observations
qui s'est fait à la grotte de lascaux
nous devons tenir compte d'une manière
plus scrupuleuse des différents
phénomènes d'agression qui sont dues aux
visites
ces visiteurs par leur respiration
apporte du gaz carbonique qui se dépose
sur les parois en formant ses voiles
blancs est le monde va pas empêcher les
touristes de respirer bien sûr seulement
alors ce qu'on peut faire
ces pompes et si vous voulez le gaz
carbonique
lorsqu'il y en a trop dans la grotte
d'autre part stériliser la grotte à
l'encré de manière à détruire
l'insémination bezzaz
alors l'une des agressions les plus
importantes du fait des visiteurs ce
sont des algues vertes
oui en effet elle se développe le plus
souvent à proximité des éclairages qui
facilite justement leur développement
mais jusqu'à présent il n'y en a pas au
niveau des peintures et encore le
visiteur est il responsable sérieux
je pense que c est véhiculée par là par
l'éditeur justement wii qui arrivent de
l'extérieur avec les semelles chargé le
sport plus ou moins et ces espèces se
déposent là et se développe justement
grâce sans doute à l'humilité à
l'éclairage enfin tout ça contribue à
leur développement
là on a un bon exemple lors de la traque
de la calcite oui absolument puisqu'on
voit quand même pas mal de deux plages
colorées
soit bien aussi de manganèse ou l oxyde
de fer mais si nous avions su ce que
nous savons aujourd'hui c'est à dire
préserver les peintures par un brossage
qui a été fait il ya quelques années
nous aurions pu la protéger comme nous
l'avons fait pour celles qui sont là
alors là venez vous il y à un bison qui
est encore extraordinairement bien
conservés dans la tête et remarquable
prévisible sur l'arrière train de vison
se trouve un cerf en superposition dont
on voit les bois pratiquement deux faces
du corps se retrouve encore assez bien à
travers quelques dépôts de calcite
encore et la barre à gauche c'est
probablement le corps d'un renne qui lui
est encore intacte très bien conservés
alors des déprédations il y en a il ya
celle de la nature ya celle de l'homme
puisque vous voyez pas mal de graffitis
malheureusement dans certaines grottes
particulièrement menacé le nombre des
visiteurs est dès à présent limité à
quelques centaines par jour
quand on sait qu'elle assurait chacune
plus de 40 mille entrées par an on peut
comprendre le mécontentement des
commerçants riverains ceux de montignac
très de lascaux ne décolère pas depuis
1962 date de la fermeture de leur grotte
oui vous savez quand ça commence à faire
mais on sait jamais quand ça va rouvrir
la fermeture des grottes de lascaux
comment ça s'est passé
c'est une catastrophe au pays il y avait
une quantité de gens qui venaient et non
seulement les pendant l'été mais pendant
l'hiver même il y avait des cars etc qui
venait avec beaucoup de personnes qui
les visitent et ce à tous les
commerçants travailler et lascaux 2
qu'est ce que vous en pensez le deuxième
lascaux lascaux bidon et bien moi je n'y
crois pas parce que je pense que j'en
veux le voir l'authentic ça ne fera pas
déplacer les gens des quatre coins du
monde comme ça c'est mon avis ou sinon
moi je suis pas de cet avis la rolls du
chercheur absolument 6,2 millions
ce soir ciel d'accord l'hérault sera
jamais qu'une reproduction se lassent
co2 bien avant d'être terminée il le
sera dans quelque 6 ou 7 ans provoque
déjà de nombreuses polémiques
il s'agit d'un fac similé creuser
artificiellement dans le rocher que l'on
prépare activement dans une petite ferme
à quelques centaines de mètres de la
grotte préhistorique les peintures
pariétales seront affirme-t-on la copie
absolument exactes de l'original
le touriste venu trop tard pour la sq au
premier ou proto pour l'aso 2 n'aura pas
nécessairement perdu son temps en
faisant halte à montignac à quelques
kilomètres de cette ville en effet il
pourra visiter le tote ou faute
d'originaux voire de copies on lui
montrera des diapositives de peintures
rupestres
ainsi que les animaux préhistoriques qui
ont servi de modèle à 12 ans